you thought this election was going to
be
between trump and biden oh you fool
you didn't realize that that there's a
third option on that ballot
that this election democracy is going to
be on the ballot this
in the words of every single democratic
official up to and including
joe biden character is on the ballot
compassion is on the ballot decency
science democracy they're all on the
ballot
who we are as a nation what we stand for
most importantly
who we want to be that's all on the
ballot
and the choice could not be more clear
democracy
is on the ballot and you only have
one choice that doesn't sound like
democracy to me i don't think democracy
is on the ballot i think democracy
is on the guillotine i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday comes from
justin who says stacey abrams has had a
long and storied political career
emphasis on the storied part which is
true because as you know stacey abrams
is the governor of georgia
and and then she became the running mate
for joe biden and i think
actually she's just already been elected
president so good for her pretty soon
she's going to be the head of the u.n
then maybe she'll go over she can become
the prime minister of
britain then who knows i mean the world
is her oyster in make believe land
actually that has a lot of bearing on
what we're talking about today because
we keep talking about democracy
democracy being on the ballot our
self-government we the people
and increasingly it's all pretend
increasingly we're just sort of
play-acting self-government
but actually all the government happens
somewhere else far away from democratic
control
and even our elections we're told only
have one legitimate answer to them
which last time i checked is not how
democracy works we'll get to that in one
second
first though oh my gosh do i get to
thank
my friends over at buttercloth so i
think the first time i did a read for
buttercloth
i hadn't gotten the shirt yet so i said
okay well you know here's what they
say about okay fine but i don't know you
you know in marketing pitches sometimes
people are a little
hyperbolic aren't they so i get my
buttercloth shirt i try this thing on
this is the single softest shirt i have
ever tried on
i said oh this must be some kind of
crazy synthetic fabric no it's cotton
just cotton but i don't know how they
did it it is the single softest shirt
i've ever worn i
i kid you not i'm probably gonna get an
hr violation because i try on my
buttercloth shirt
i run around the office telling people
to feel me feel my shirt feel grab my
arm grab my chest i don't
i don't i hope hr is not watching the
show this thing is unbelievable and then
they have one kind of shirt
which has these mint fibers in it where
the minute you put it on
it cools your skin down very important
now as we're in a heat wave in la and
i guess in dc and everywhere else i
travel you gotta head on over right now
buttercloth is offering our listeners
twenty percent off your first purchase
go to buttercloth.com
knowles canon wles you will receive 20
off your first full price order that is
buttercloth.com
knowles you will thank me i assure you
i don't think that this election is
about
democracy so much i mean maybe it is in
a sense democracy is on the ballot
because you've got one candidate
president trump who is running and
saying look
the the government bureaucracy the
establishment has taken way too much
power
we're going to put it back in your hands
then you've got another party that says
absolutely not
any election that we lose is
illegitimate we're going to take away
choice from you
i think that black lives matter is
actually
much more honest than joe biden joe
biden says democracies on the ballot
black lives matter says that if you
don't vote for us we're going to kill
you
here is a black lives matter activist
explaining
her demands this is our city
our worst city and we're taking this
back point blank period
end of discussion we have demands and
they need to be met and i feel like i've
been saying this
too much we're not asking you anything
we're telling you what's about to happen
with your permission
or not
i don't want to come out here again i
don't want to have to do this again
i don't want to take a day i
unfortunately was not at the action
yesterday
i was actually taking a day between this
organizing
because it's taxing work because we are
kids
trying to grow up and i took a day to
myself
to wake up to find out that my friends
are being abused
by the police you can listen to
us or you can get ran over
[Applause]
and that's all i have to say listen to
us
or get ran over right it's run over but
that's sort of a side point i think
actually what she's saying
though ungrammatical is completely
honest and it's actually the same thing
that democrats are saying
i i think right now what the what the
democratic party especially the biden
part of the party wants to say is
those blm people they're radical they're
not us we're the more moderate we're the
adults in the room
actually they're saying the same thing
they're saying give us exactly what we
want
or we're just going to take it from you
right we're going to pretend that this
is democratic choice we're going to
pretend
that you can go and actually voice your
opinion on politics
but not really because if you vote for
trump if accidentally trump gets elected
we're just gonna spend four years trying
to oust him we're gonna use the
administrative government to undermine
him then we're gonna try to impeach him
we're gonna impeach him over russia or
we're gonna impeach him over taxes or
we're gonna impeach him over ukraine
which is at war with russia we're just
give us what we want or get run over
this is this is what children say
actually that woman in the clip says
we're kids she doesn't look like a kid
to me she
looks fairly grown she's behaving like a
kid but she looks grown up
and the democrats are doing the same
thing joe biden certainly doesn't look
like a kid but he's behaving like one
hillary clinton doesn't look like a kid
but she's behaving like one
the issue here is whether or not we can
have self-government
to have self-government you have to be
willing to lose sometimes
you have to be willing to give some
power to the people
this is why if you go back to the civil
war right the issue with
the there are many issues in the civil
war but the reason why secession
actually happened why the
why the work kicked off is because you
you
had one side saying we cannot have
self-government
if you can have secession then you can't
have self-government because it means
that as long as you win
as long as you get everything you want
then you'll stay part of the union but
if not you'll take your ball and go home
and you there's there's no way a free
government can exist that way
people are trying to make the case that
joe biden and bernie sanders are very
different right
that's it this is the case we've heard
you've got the biden side of the party
and the sanders side of the party
well i don't think they're so different
barack obama made this point and i think
he's right
if you look at joe biden's goals and
bernie sanders goals they're not that
different from a 40
000 foot level said barack obama to the
new yorker
they both want to make sure i'll do it
my obama voice they both want to make
sure
everybody has health care they want to
make sure everybody can get a job that
pays a living wage
they want to make sure every child gets
a good education
okay i think he's putting a little bit
of a gloss on what they both want
but the fact that he's saying from a 40
000 foot level it's the same thing
is absolutely correct from a 40 000 foot
level what the democratic party wants
and blm wants
is the same thing why because they both
share the same vision of politics and
history
they both and it's the same vision obama
shares which is the arc of history bends
toward justice
you can be on the right side of history
or the wrong side of history look we're
all going to move toward a socialist
utopia eventually where we diminish the
role of national governments and
sovereignty and move toward
a larger international government that's
a venture we know that's going to happen
that is the future the only question is
do you do it quickly like bernie sanders
wants
do you do it quickly like blm wants or
do you do it a little more slowly
like joe biden wants or do you do it a
little bit more slowly than that
like most republicans want it seems like
everybody agrees
okay you say democracy is on the ballot
i say it's donald
trump against the world i say that
actually the entire left and a segment
of the right
don't really believe in democratic
choice whatsoever
and one of the few weirdos who does is
donald trump
who doesn't just go along to get along
with the administrative
government with this this view of
history that is always progressing
in one direction all right what about
actual politics what about actual
democratic choice
what about actual political change trump
tries that every so often
right so we're in this covet lockdown
we're in the dictatorship of the lab
coats here
where all of our political rights are
now being dictated to us by people that
we didn't elect like the exalted dr
fauci
peace be upon him so yesterday president
trump tweets out he says i've got a big
announcement coming at 5 30.
the announcement is that there's a
breakthrough in covid treatment
that's sort of a separate issue maybe
we'll get into that later in the week i
actually think that's the secondary
that's the part everyone's talking about
but i think it's the
of secondary importance to how this
breakthrough was arrived at here is
president trump thanking
his fda the fda
has issued an emergency use
authorization and that's such a a
powerful term
emergency use authorization for a
treatment known as convalescent plasma
this is a powerful therapy
that transfuses very very strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
it's had an incredible rate of success
today's action will dramatically expand
access to this treatment and i want to
thank
dr han and secretary azar i want to
thank the fda
all of the people that have been working
very hard on this it showed tremendous
potential
so this is great news on kovid right
but what about on our government you
have the duly elected president of the
united states
announcing with glee an announcement
that one of his administrative agencies
has made he's so excited
[Music]
that an administrative agency has made
this breakthrough but why doesn't he
have more control
over that administrative agency you know
this this announcement comes just a day
or so
after president trump announces uh
on twitter that the deep state at the
fda
is not allowing him to pursue progress
on this issue
because they want to basically keep the
country locked down until november
that was the claim that was made
regardless of the merits of that of the
the actual
scientific discoveries that are being
undertaken
the question is one of political power
why is there such a gap
between the fda and trump who's
theoretically the boss of the fda
the white house chief of staff mark
meadows explains exactly what's going on
it ties right in with what the democrats
are telling you we'll get to that in one
second
first though i gotta thank our friends
over at eero these days
your house is not just your home is it
it's in some ways it's not your home
anymore because it's your office it's
the place you never leave it's the place
where you do every single thing that you
do
it's a school it's a movie theater it's
everything you can't leave so you know
what i got to tell you you got to make
sure your wi-fi works
okay that is now a prerequisite in the
year 2020. so eero is an amazon company
covers your whole home
with fast reliable wi-fi inside and out
have you ever had this in your home
maybe it's maybe it's just the bad
houses that i've lived in
you'll just have dead spots for your
wi-fi and i don't know why i don't have
the scientific knowledge as to why that
is but it happens
ero totally fixes it okay eero
it's it's amazing if they set it up you
you do not drop your wi-fi anywhere and
my favorite part about ero is you know
i'm not exactly technologically savvy
eero is so simple even i can set it up
and it takes
no time it's the ease of use is really
unbelievable check it out right now
we're asking a lot of our wi-fi euro can
help
yours do more go to eero.com knowles
canon wles
enter code knowles easy to remember
canon wlas
uh you will get free next day shipping
with your order eero.com
knowles code knowles at checkout to get
your eero delivered with free
next day shipping go to eero eero dot
com
slash knowles code knowles go check it
out
mark meadows explains why it's been so
hard
to to wrangle the administrative
agencies he explains
on george stephanopoulos's show that
there is
a deep state in the government
what evidence does the president have
that the fda is manipulating this
process approval process for political
reasons
well i your your words are manipulating
at george
i don't think he said they they were
manipulating but i can't tell you
obviously i can help you i've been
personally involved in this so i'll be
glad to tell you here's what we
we continue to look at and it's not just
the fda it's nih and others
as we look at the protocols and and dr
hahn was
very right to say we're not going to cut
any corners because we're not cutting
any corners
but what we have is we have a china
virus that came here
we've got to deliver answers and the
president each and every day is saying
why don't we have an answer today why
don't we have an answer tomorrow
and so what happens is is that we
continue to look at some of the trials
and what's happening
and and we we want to wear belt and
suspenders the way that some of these
bureaucrats want to look at they want to
do things the way they've always done it
this president is about cutting red tape
that's what the tweet was all about
that's what the tweet was all about what
was the tweet what did it say trump
tweets out
quote the deep state or whoever over at
the fda is making it very difficult for
drug companies to get people
in order to test the vaccines and
therapeutics obviously they're hoping to
delay the answer
until after november 3rd my focus on
speed and saving lives
or we must focus on speed and saving
lives and then he tags the fda guy
this is obviously true there are
bureaucrats
right now who are trying to delay things
until november 3rd you have whole school
districts that say they're going to open
on november 6th
right basically they're going to keep
this whole [ __ ] down until the election
make everybody miserable
other places around the world opening up
it's it's just not
an issue anymore in a in this
politicized sense
but other countries around the world
don't have a very important presidential
election coming up so that's what's
going on there's a huge political
incentive
to keep the country locked down trump is
trying to wrangle them but stefanopoulos
then asks
what i think is a perfectly natural
follow-up question if you're not that
familiar with the government
stephanopoulos is familiar with the
government so i think from him it's a
little disingenuous but the question is
if trump's not happy with the fda why
doesn't he just fire them
why doesn't he fire the head of the fda
why doesn't he fire other people
first of all well there are a few
reasons one
even if you fire the head of the fda
you've still got the whole
entity you've still got the whole
administration here
and and the simple fact is the president
can barely fire federal employees
it's extraordinarily difficult to fire
federal employees
even though they work for trump that's
the way our government works now
it is almost impossible isn't that a
little weird
no this is a process that's been
building for a hundred years now
it was envisioned by woodrow wilson it
was sort of laid out the architecture
was built
fdr implemented it it was expanded under
lbj
and now we have a shadow government but
except it's not really
shadow in that we know it exists it's
all these alphabet agencies
but they they govern in the shadows and
even the president of the united states
the leader of the free world
can't get total control over it so he's
got to pressure them on twitter
you know people always say trump's got
to get off twitter why is he always
tweeting why are
if you even look outside of trump why
are all these congressmen and senators
and government why do they why do they
go on
television all the time instead of doing
their job well it's because
actually communicating is
pretty much the only tool left to them
because so much of government
has been outsourced to the
administrative state you want to hear
how
crazy it is the duly elected president
of the united states
can barely change his garden
without people losing their minds
that he's usurping power the guard the
rose garden melania trump
redesigned the rose garden sort of what
did she do
she took 10 crab apple trees that were
part of jackie kennedy's design
back in the 60s and she moved them from
the garden to another part of the white
house grounds
and she did this because the trees had
grown so much that they were casting too
much shadow on other parts and it was
messing up part of the garden this is
not
exactly uh you know world war three here
right this is not exactly
nuclear negotiations with north korea
and yet twitter went crazy the
mainstream media went crazy
the the journalists went crazy because
she moved some crab apple trees
think about how desiccated our view of
politics is
you know one issue we get into as
conservatives is we always say we want
more limited government we want
government to do less
but that's a little bit imprecise
because we've got
we've got our political process and then
we've got this kind of
government that actually isn't that open
to the political process and what i
think we should be more specific
we want that government that's not at
all accountable we want them to do less
and stop regulating every single little
aspect of our lives
but we do want an authentic politics we
do want to be able to voice our opinion
and have that opinion
actually matter in politics i think a
lot of the donald trump election in 2016
is people saying our voice is not being
heard in politics
even when we elect the people who are
running ostensibly on our program they
get into office they don't do anything
and they don't do anything not just
because they're lazy though never
underestimate the laziness of
politicians they don't do anything
because they actually can't do anything
there's nothing
for them to do and so people get a
little frustrated want to work
outside of the the main framework
frankly i think this is true
in some ways of black lives matter black
lives matter is a marxist organization
that is utterly antithetical to america
which
which we'll get into in just one second
but they are expressing that same kind
of frustration
and all i know is there are historical
parallels here
to very difficult times in american
history where you see the country kind
of unraveling
the only way that you're going to be
able to let some of the steam
out of that is to give people more of a
say in their government because
now on both sides of the aisle people
feel that they have no say
and they're turning against the system
itself you want to hear that democracy
is on the ballot democracy's on the
guillotine
quite quite literally on the guillotine
in portland
the portland riots still going on it's
still causing absolute mayhem
portland is at this point essentially a
failed state
so the the protesters now again i gotta
give them credit
like blm like some more radical parts of
the democratic coalition
they're being honest about their views
they're now wheeling a guillotine
into the middle of their demonstration
we've been calling them these
jacobin revolutionaries for a while now
so they've got the mechanism of radical
revolution they've got a guillotine
what do they put in the guillotine an
american flag which they set on fire and
then they guillotine which seems like
overkill to me
but you can watch it happening now
you can see someone walking over
sets the fire the crowd cheers
[Music]
black lives matter they chant there it
is
you can you can hear it it you can't
deny it
once you once you see it once you hear
it black lives matter is the chant
of burning the american flag and of
course it is because the premise of
black lives matter
is on the on the most shallow level
that america is an evil country that's
hopelessly racist that can never be
redeemed and we need to overthrow the
government
and overthrow the traditional society
and then
when you look a little bit more deeply
into it you see the founders actually
say we are trained marxists we want to
obliterate the nuclear family
we want to obliterate all of the
american institutions
and then this the flag is a symbol of
the whole country this is why it was so
egregious when colin kaepernick decided
to protest the flag
because he's not just protesting some
aspect of america he's protesting
the whole damn thing which they're now
doing setting it ablaze putting it on
the
chopping block in in portland
and i think they're expressing the view
throughout the entire
country does the press cover that no
probably the only place
that you're hearing about what's
actually going on in portland is perhaps
on this show
maybe on andy noe's twitter feed in very
limited segments here but that's the
debate
and the reason the colin kaepernick
protest
it bothered me because i love my country
but it also bothered me because it was
so incoherent
colin kaepernick said i have a first
amendment right in america granted to me
in this constitution
and so i'm going to use that right to
burn the symbol of the country that
gives me that first amendment right
that doesn't make any sense doesn't make
any sense
same thing with with putting the flag in
the guillotine
right you can't say my i'm using my free
expression
to burn the flag to torch the flag well
then you don't get the free expression
right that is an incoherent protest
and the press don't cover it at all
we'll get to we'll get to trump calling
out the press in just one second
first though got to thank our friends
over at netsuite by oracle the world's
number one
cloud business system so i've worked on
a number of of
startup companies smaller companies some
have grown into bigger companies
the number one thing i notice that stops
companies from growing is they don't
know their numbers they can't keep track
they've got a whole different hodgepodge
of systems
and the systems are not speaking to one
another and i
promise you if you lose sight of some of
your numbers that can have huge
consequences it can cost you your
business down the line
with netsuite you can keep track of
finance you can keep track of hr
you can keep track of e-commerce
everything you need all in one place
so you save time money and headaches
doesn't matter if you're doing tens of
millions in sales hundreds of millions
in sales
netsuite gives you visibility and
control maybe you're doing a million
dollars
doesn't matter you can manage every
penny with precision
twenty thousand customers trust netsuite
to go faster with confidence so right
now they've got a free guide for you
obviously this is a good time to pay a
lot of attention to your business
they've got this free guide seven
actions businesses need to take now
you can also schedule your product tour
at netsuite.com
knowles canada w l e s get your free
guide schedule your free product tour
netsuite.com knowles what is that
address very simple netsuite.com
slash knowles the press aren't covering
any of this remember the press the great
defenders of democracy
no they're not they agree with with joe
biden they agree with antifa they agree
with blm
which is that we've our democracy is at
stake and you only have one choice so
president trump jokes with them
he comes out at the press briefing and
he
he wishes them well on the convention
that they just had
good to see you all hope you had a great
weekend at your convention that
is their convention the dnc is the
prez's convention
you heard ryan lizza this left-wing
journalist who said barack obama's
convention speech is the greatest
convention speech ever since his last
one which was so great
it wasn't great it was a bad speech and
his first convention speech wasn't that
great either
do you remember the first one that gave
barack obama a national political career
this this is the most brilliant
periclean line in the whole speech
because
there's not a red america there's not a
blue america there's a united states of
america
there's not a white america there's not
a black america the united states of
america
wow stirring rhetoric i'd never
considered that
you're saying we're one country wow oh
my gosh it's like i'm listening to
abraham lincoln or something
no it's not it's very very weak sauce
but they fell in love with obama they
love the guy
and the same thing happened at the this
democratic national convention
trump's longest lasting legacy
i think i mentioned this on the show
last week it's not gonna be the judges
it's not gonna be the executive orders
it's not gonna be
tax reform or anything like that it's
going to be
exposing the press as part of the
democratic party
and even beyond the democratic party
even is just one constituency of it what
we're really talking about is a liberal
establishment that includes the
democratic party
it includes these terrorists on the
street blm and antifa
though that's the that's the military
wing of the liberal establishment
you've got the administrative government
of the liberal establishment they're the
ones actually
passing all of the all of the laws
totally unaccountable
and then you've got the media which is
the propaganda wing of the liberal
establishment
but it's all working in tandem
the communications director of the dnc
is not the propaganda wing of the
liberal establishment
it's the whole it's the whole mainstream
media that's what that's the propaganda
way
and so when you look at that in a way
you see democracy is on the ballot
because
you've got this one guy donald trump
a few other candidates but obviously
trump is is the most prominent and
successful
in my lifetime who stand up against this
thing
and against even the squishy republicans
who really
just want to go along with that
establishment albeit a little bit slower
they won't cover anything you you know
there's a little story
probably the only place you would have
heard about it is on donald trump's
twitter feed during the dnc
during the convention during two caucus
meetings
they said the pledge of allegiance well
good for them i'm shocked they even did
that
but these leaders of the caucus meetings
left out the phrase
under god pledge of allegiance very i
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america to the republic
for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all we used to learn that as
school children probably they don't
learn that now
the democrats because they're still
catering to an older generation they say
it
but they take out under god now i've
been told reliably by usa today
fact check dnc did not omit under god
from the pledge of allegiance
snope says this is mostly false all the
other mainstream media misleading not
true
false take a listen to the opening
of the muslim caucus of the democratic
national
convention i pledge allegiance to the
flag
of the united states of america and to
the republic for which it stands
one nation indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
take a listen to the opening of the lgbt
caucus of the democratic national
convention
hello everybody if you don't have a flag
i have flags here
right in front of me please place your
hand over your heart
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all we have them on video we have
the audio we have the receipts and this
lying dishonest mainstream media
are going to look us right in the face
and say no
you didn't hear that no you didn't hear
that that didn't happen
who are you going to believe us or your
lion ears
that is the i think even conservatives
don't appreciate
how thoroughly dishonest the press is
it's not just that george stephanopoulos
works for
bill clinton for many years and then he
becomes a fake journalist
and oh he's obviously got a bias it's
that
this entire apparatus exists to
not not only to lie to you not only
it exists to help the liberal
establishment
and so if it if it helps the liberal
establishment to tell the truth they'll
do it
but if it helps the liberal
establishment to obscure the truth
they'll do it and if it helps the
liberal establishment to
outright lie even when we've got the
audio they will do that
it's pure cynicism and self-government
cannot operate that way self-government
requires
an understanding of objective truth
self-government requires that we be able
to communicate with one another
self-government requires a legitimate
choice
and we are being denied that choice by
that liberal establishment and what do
they do you know the left always
projects
so they always say trump's a fascist
trump's an authoritarian
trump is the most democratic candidate
that we have had in this government
maybe in a hundred years certainly in 30
years
but i don't know maybe in 100 years
you're getting a legitimate
choice here and
they're they're they're denying that to
you they're telling you that it is
exactly the opposite we'll get to
another this is this is the craziest
story because you know the left always
talks about science we'll get to a real
science denying story
we'll get to some double standards first
though
i've got to tell you to head on over to
my youtube channel thank you so much to
everyone who has done that
we we have exclusive content up there
that you're not going to get elsewhere
i just did an interview with my friend
paul kanger who has a book out called
the devil and karl marx and i actually
wrote the four words of that book
i don't get a royalty though so i'm only
telling you to go buy it because it is
an
excellent book so many people focus on
the economic and political side of marx
this book focuses on marx's spiritual
life and it is dark
and scary and very very bad but you
should know it because because nobody's
going to tell you about it you're not
going to learn about this in school
i head on over there we did an interview
about that it got it got pretty graphic
i got to tell you i didn't know paul
would get so well anyway you'll have to
go check out the interview yourself
uh then head on over we're gonna have a
backstage coming up at the end of the
week
to talk about the rnc and also you
should go to all access this is our
elite tier of membership this is where
you get to participate in all access
hangouts with the other members of the
website in all access
and with the hosts and with the writers
go to dailywire.com
knowles right now you can get 20 off and
not one but two
two leftist tiers tumblers how's that uh
using
access code access
access code access go to dailywire.com
use the code
access you'll get 20 off and two
tumblers
and then stay right there we'll be back
with a lot more
to show you you know pulling back a
little bit from the outright lies
that the press tells you where you can
actually listen to the audio and then
they deny it exists
i'll give you a more typical example
of of how they do these things this is
from
abc news state department fighting to
deny
u.s citizenship to gay couples child
that's terrible isn't it you got this
american couple
who i guess they're being discriminated
against because they're gay
and they've got their child and the
child is being denied citizenship that's
just so wait hold on a second here
wait hold up wait what was that headline
state department fighting to deny us
citizenship to gay couples
child gay couples child
i i'm no biologist okay i'm no
i'm an expert scientist but i'm not you
know i'm not specifically a biologist
but it seems to me if i go back to my
elementary learning of how
children are made where babies come from
gay couples can't have children by
themselves right that doesn't
doesn't work that way so wait a second
maybe there's more to this
headline maybe there's more to this
story than meets the eye well of course
there is
two gentlemen by the name of roey cavity
and adil kavidi living in chevy chase
maryland are legally married under the
new definition of marriage
they're both u.s citizens their daughter
kasem was born in canada
via a surrogate so the state department
has argued in federal court that she's
born out of wedlock and not entitled to
birthright citizenship
there are so many things wrong with this
story first of all we talked about this
issue last week when we were discussing
kamala harris's eligibility for vice
president the question of birthright
citizenship is granted by the 14th
amendment
is very much an open legal question the
supreme court has never held
that there is blanket birthright
citizenship for anybody
who happens to be born on u.s soil so
that's that's one issue that's wrong
with it
then the the child was born out of
wedlock well
of course the child was born out of
wedlock first of all given the
definition of marriage but even under
the new definition of marriage
that has come about not through
democratic choice whenever this was put
on the ballot even in very democratic
states
people rejected radically redefining
marriage because it's the bedrock
institution of society
but even using the new definition of of
marriage
the two these two men obviously can't
have a child together so that
the actual parents of this child are one
of these men
and this woman and the child is being
denied her natural mother
intentionally how insane a legal system
do we have
that a child can intentionally be denied
her natural mother awful stuff
you know all the focus is only put in
this political issue
on how this gay couple really wants to
have a child but because of nature they
can't have a child together
no no thought is put on this little girl
who will never be able to know her
mother her natural mother
who will be created in a legal regime
that only prioritizes the desires of the
parents to overcome the limitations of
nature
and will never be directed toward the
the natural needs of the child that's
the second part the third part is this
happened in canada
there's no and yet so
there are so many layers here of why
this is this shouldn't even be a
headline
child is born out of wedlock in canada
and is not a us citizen
yeah duh shouldn't even be a headline
but
it serves so many aspects of
the liberal establishment's goals namely
to radically redefine
every institution that threatens any of
the political power of the growing
liberal state
most notably most importantly the family
which
the left and the the progressive
establishment has been after
explicitly you can read it in their
writings for well over a hundred years
it goes back further to that fellow i
was just mentioning mr karl marx
then you have another priority here
which is
open borders right the liberal
establishment wants open borders because
it diminishes the political sovereignty
of the people the ability of the people
to
determine their own politics and
government
and it encourages trade it encourages
uh keeping wages down it encourages
everything
that this group of people wants
and that's the way the story is
presented that if you just if you just
any normal person just looks at that
headline
state department denying u.s citizenship
to gay couples child you'd say oh that's
wrong
right that sounds wrong and then you
read the story you realize
how wrong it is same you know you can
even see this in the stories they don't
run
so the nba the nba which i don't watch
has these two players montrezl harrell
and luca
doncic i'm i'm certain i didn't
pronounce this correctly but
sort of secondary to my point so they
were playing a basketball game
and uh mr harrell uh
made a good shot or something and so as
he was walking away after this great
play you can see him mouth on camera
into close-up
the phrase well bleep me if i i think
i'm allowed to say
bitch-ass white boy that was the phrase
that he said i don't know if i don't
know if i'm allowed to say that on the
air but if i'm not you know just bleep
me
that's what he says it's like uh it's
like whap
but another but that's a variation of
that phrase
now people in the heat of sports these
are
obviously top athletes these are intense
competitors you're going to say things
you're going to say rude things mean
things get in each other's heads
so i don't really blame this guy however
imagine if it were reversed
imagine if it weren't a black athlete
saying that to a white athlete but a
white athlete
making a similar comment to a black
athlete
you would have wall-to-wall coverage 24
7 news
not only would the team be shut down the
league would be shut down maybe the
country would be shut down
with protests but
the reason that media and the liberal
establishment would encourage that
is because it would serve their ends of
sowing discord
diminishing american political unity
diminishing the ability of
the american citizens to speak to one
another to communicate
to to determine in our own deliberative
bodies
how to govern ourselves and
by pushing or by ignoring this story
they move right along they continue to
stoke the flames of racial division
when it comes to blm never never any
story on the other way
there is a degree of victimhood that
that has now it's taken on such status
it's taken on such prestige it confers
such privilege
that you now have candidates for
political office not making
keen logical arguments for what they
want to do and why their their set of
policies is better than their opponent
set of policies
they're they're faking their own
kidnappings
to give themselves the illusion of that
privilege and they'll hope that that
wins there's a
there's a woman in sumter south carolina
29 years old sabrina belcher
who ran as not the candidate who
believes this
or that not the candidate who's going to
push for this or that policy
she fashioned herself quote the first
black female candidate ever to run
which is something i don't care about i
don't i don't care if she's the first
female black can i care about what she's
going to do
right i mean i don't live in in sumter
south carolina but if i were a citizen
there
or if i were voting for a candidate in
my own jurisdiction
i would care about what they are going
to do what they believe
what what what they represent is a
matter of
policy and politics but that doesn't
matter anymore now people are only
running on identity and
through identity victimhood so this
woman
was apparently assaulted and kidnapped
by 34 year old christopher edie take a
listen to the video that
for some reason conspicuously and
coincidentally
all of this was caught on video
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm sorry
[Music]
all right looks like it's stop smoking
everything right
now stop it
tell your mother
oh gosh this is getting even worse this
is some
she's so afraid with hollywood shut down
obviously someone's got to create
content for the public and i guess now
it's mayoral candidates in sumter south
carolina
because every single second of that was
completely faked
this woman planned it all out with uh mr
edie beforehand
this is not the first time we've seen
this this is just the latest
in a line of of actors some professional
like jessie smallett
walking through maga country in chicago
and some amateur like
like ms what's her name belcher
like ms belcher who are putting on these
kinds of performances
because they see that the fastest way
to political cachet the fastest way to
political change
is not by making honest arguments it's
by putting on
dishonest performances it's by tricking
the public it's through smoke and
mirrors
now why is this one people are emotional
and if you play on people's emotions and
appetites and hysteria
you're likely to get a reaction but in
the long run what does that lead to it
leads to the collapse of your lit
physical country that we can see all
around us
and it leads to the collapse of your
politics bill de blasio
was just asked in new york when the city
is going to open back up
what the plan is you know 15 days to
slow the spread do you remember that it
was about 160 days ago at this point
and and now it's i don't know when when
are we going to reopen maybe sometime in
2024 or something i don't know
so de blasio's asked when are you going
to open up indoor dining at least
what is the plan you know what his plan
is he has no plan
there is not a context for indoor dining
we're never saying it's impossible
uh but we do not based on what we've
seen around the world
we do not have a plan for reopening
indoor dining in the near term
of course they don't have a plan they
don't need a plan
they don't need to tell the american
people what they're going to do
because they have the right to rule
because it's not even about democrat or
republican or left or right i mean
they do happen to be mostly democrats
they do happen to be left-wing but they
feel
ultimately that they are the ruling
class and they are they are the ruling
class
and they will make whatever decision
they want and they'll tell you whatever
they
they think you need to hear to make it
go down a little easier
but ultimately they're going to do
whatever they want
to do that is not
democratic government you know blue
check twitter went crazy yesterday
because uh president trump announced the
republican party it's not gonna have a
real platform this year you know the
parties go to the conventions they write
these platforms but it doesn't really
matter because
at least for the last you know 100 or so
years the president
and the presidential nominee is the
platform he
is the leader of the party this was also
envisioned by woodrow wilson
that the president would become the
leader of the party so
trump says okay i'm not going to waste
we're not going to waste time on this
platform i'm just going to give you my
second term agenda
and we can get into the second term
agenda a little bit later in the week
there's just
one part that made the commentariat the
twitterratty go crazy
and it was that he said as part of his
education plan
he's going to teach american
exceptionalism
very simple this this was this would
have been
not only non-controversial this would
have been
understood expected until very recently
and the left went nuts and a lot of
teachers on twitter said i'm a teacher
i'm not teaching american exceptional
ones america's terrible america is an
awful place
what is american exceptionalism some
people interpret this to mean that
america is the single greatest
perfect nation ever and it doesn't do
anything wrong that's not what american
exceptionalism means
it means because of america's unique
history and founding it's different than
other countries
which is obviously true america is a
country that was founded
in a new world with very distinct
highly conscious political principles
in a period of time when people were
focusing in
on the mechanisms of government in in a
more abstracted way than than
many people had in the past
that is by definition true what is an
aspect of american exceptionalism
this focus on a particularly 18th
century conception
of liberty that does in fact draw on the
ancients
this conception of liberty and
self-government and how we
rule our own country that is that is
american exceptionalism
and it should come as no surprise that
the left
laughs at it and mocks it it's it's not
just that the left you know
sort of hates the country and they're
burning the american flag
they they don't believe in this and they
have been saying at least since woodrow
wilson
that they want to get rid of that they
openly mock it they say i mean if you
read the writings of wilson
he'll say look the american constitution
was founded on the principles of isaac
newton
you know these kind of eternal laws that
balance power against each other
but that's all bs we've had a new
scientific achievement we've got charles
darwin
and charles darwin is
shows us that nothing is objective
everything is
on a continuum everything is progressing
and evolving so we just need
power like an organism to do whatever we
want those are opposing views of america
that's
it's why it's important to overturn and
rewrite the history of america pull down
the statues of america
and tear down what we would call the
traditional american nation to
enact that kind of politics and most
importantly
they've got to blot out democracy
republican government
self-rule because that presumes that
people have
enduring rights that aren't just going
to go away
as the organism evolves
what the left is trying to impose on us
democracy is on the ballot
damn right i guess it is and when they
tell you there's only one legitimate
choice you can make
then you know they've taken it and put
it on the ballot perhaps
but they're not going to read your
ballots because they're going to put it
first on the guillotine that's our show
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen